each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay thanks for attending so I'm going
to be talking about the review i'm at
PSC we do have performance computing a
very traditional computational intensive
I'm going to be talking about the
expanding role of data in scientific
analysis so there's actually thinking
those companion talked to the last type
of day that Ralph Ross keys in front row
Megalodon are giving the titles on the
agenda or very similar but we were
conscious to cover different things so
you both please ok so what want to talk
about first of all few acknowledgments
here in the slides first of all in terms
of the abundance of data so it certainly
as was point out yesterday it's kind of
amusing how many these talks have the
same theme depart them we certainly had
a nice collaboration through centuries
between observation theory and pretty
much single guys getting nice ideas
Along Came simulation large computing
strument let people do things a lot more
aggressively let them explore larger
models somewhat larger collaborations
what we have now though is certainly a
regime where we have large-scale data
collections we don't have a pointer do
we ok ah thank you yes so we have
large-scale data collections and what
these really enabling is as we've seen
throughout this being much larger
collaborations that's partly driven by
just the nature of the additional work
needed to do the theory to implement the
computer codes to do the visual analysis
and do other things but it's also
reaching out and the ter Greg we call
these things science gateways and the
idea is that by enabling user-friendly
interfaces to some things we can bring
more people in and perhaps make them
more accessible to others then the
domain experts and tides all that where
this talk once I want to address is also
a coupling of that to the increased
importance of doing the large-scale data
analysis and how that relates to overall
io bandwidth whether they have us beyond
your
local disk system or over the network
and hopefully that will all put together
let's keep on generating some new good
ideas well yes the light bulb changes
okay the point that's talked though is
not row the scientific applications my
career I'll forget about those much more
detail at four o'clock today I have some
of those examples and motivators but
really wanna make the point that we've
always known at least some of us always
recognized the high end simulation you
really need system balance you don't
just need lots of flops you need balance
i/o performance memory bandwidth and so
on where we're looking really large data
that we're large data today can be tens
of terabytes in a future will certainly
be into petabytes and beyond that's
really places band with the premium
whether it's io bandwidth or memory
bandwidth really both the things driving
that our simulation results obviously
all the sensory day we've seen
throughout this meeting and elsewhere
where sensory data includes experimental
data they're coming in the things like
it UWM milla genomics and other fields
now this socio-economic things that may
come from economics from network
analysis additionally this data could be
multimodal it can be structured it can
be a nice CFD things that we the unset
example is brought before those have any
nice gridded data it also be highly
unstructured and so we really want to
focus on this we have applications
across the board this is just serve a
collage of things from oceanography to
biology all of these have high data or
memory intensive needs on them some of
the more novel things here or network
analysis you're from the connectome it
under chang'aa how human proteins relate
this is a an application that will be
highlighting a supercomputing looking at
poker is a game of incomplete knowledge
and that turns out to be a highly memory
intensive task and very large memory to
do the analysis to get the get
reasonable strategies for checking these
sorts of problems
so there are several use cases for data
what at least what I think of the data
intensive computing and there should be
more these were a few that fit well for
this talk and so first of all for dating
tens competing I think this is something
where we have a predominant bandwidth
component that we remember down with
where I 0 or both depend how large the
data size actually is relative to the
amount of computation you actually have
to do so first we have the data parallel
analyses we see a lot of them in this
meeting these are things that fit very
well and say a Hadoop MapReduce model
where you have a very embarrassingly
parallel very separable task with
reasonably high computational intensity
there also a bunch of other things out
there are things where you'd like to do
interactive queries I'm very large data
sets and many of these is a query
especially complex you may have to do
things across the data a lot of examples
adapt in unpredictable directions for
which you need a fairly tight coupling
there are also various monolithic data
sets for Instagram pool in the climate
community or the individual data sets
will be tens of terabytes as of today
one can imagine chardon goes into
MapReduce pieces but inherently the
services that people want to do on these
today is heavily synchronized you'd be
waiting on the slowest component so
there can still be advantages to having
a more tightly coupled analysis and the
other example I have is for really
highly index data there are things again
like they're being done that EWW in
Quinn's group where in cosmology have
octrees another very highly structured
data and in those cases that the
inherent indexing index can give you
advantages in the analysis and so are
things like that we really need a lot of
bandwidth to get from whatever the
persistent storages and so I want
mentioned it persistent storage some
have I think it's being underestimated
anymore people especially meetings like
this figure that you can have a data
intensive resource and you can do your
computation that's all well and good
provide you can store everybody's data
but until we have enough computers for
everybody to do this there will be
competition for these
and so one has thing about how you stage
data again how you staged it out and how
you move data between different user
jobs so a few examples I want to use
motivate this one is that we do analyses
with University Oklahoma every year on
prediction of severe storms and there's
what they call it spring campaign to
coincide with tornado season when
tornadoes plow across middle the United
States to do real-time data assimilation
get predictions for the next few hours
I'm these involved this spring heavy
computation ons Big Ben which is next to
three at pittsburgh some computation
crackin at the university of tennessee
oakridge and also some work in oklahoma
so i'm going to focus on the PSC piece
because this is one that actually
involved it fairly heavy data transfer
so i have until to what time I just want
til 215 ok ok so I'll keep moving fast
so anyway this is running a PSC I'd like
800 cores of Big Ben these are things
you run daily at pre-scheduled times
they produce a variety of data products
ensemble forecasts in different
modalities and that gets us to sometimes
broke earlier in this session day which
was the insert the importance of
predicting the of knowing uncertainty of
your predictions the data transfers for
this we're about one half terabyte today
or 1.25 terabyte today and then there
were some one in Pittsburgh this is a
case now where we have data that's being
computed and assimilated from different
sources in the field like radar and
coming across and then the data are
being collected another quick example
Washoe to move HS is sort of scale of
multiple terabytes per day now he is
from high speed transmission electron
microscopy this image from Harvard where
the instrument actually lives what we're
doing is producing these slices across
biological data mechanics aside to give
you an idea data size this one slice of
the image the little rectangle the
bottom right is the visible human data
set that was so popular what six years
ago so around there so each slice of
this data set dwarfs the full visible
human data set we're going to see we're
going to simulate massive vault numbers
these slices to reconstruct volumes now
this is at 40 nanometers per pixel at
that scale we can't yet do the
connectivity to look at synapses and
actually build the 3d structure but
cells going down to four nano meters per
pixel now we can actually start seeing
synaptic junctions and so the problem
changes to one of segmentation image
reconstruction building 3d morphology so
what they really want to do over the
next six months is due 10 terabyte data
sets of this Andy vote eventually
evolved up to into the connectome which
is going to be a model all to say a
cubic millimeter human brain in terms of
data movement what's significant here is
just we're looking at data coming from
Harvard across a raid device there into
an archiver PSC and well I just want the
bumper speed so the take-home messages
here were that the web performance was
below the line down with deaths that's
we found all the time so when people
type of moving data for grid doing these
days of computing challenges I'll show
that a little more my next example one
actually has to do a lot of
experimentation allowed tuning to do
this we've done a lot of tuning of
networks themselves we have a group at
PSC who does network performance
analysis in tuning and also working on
an improved scps and so on the other
thing this group really learned was the
importance of check something finding
just random data loss all through the
pipeline the last detail example uh
cover is a pan store as telescope this
was mentioned at least once at this
meeting no more detail here the
centerpiece of this they're very a
phenomenally good 30k by 30k pixel ccd
camera again it produces these very
detailed maps the key thing though here
is that the telescope was in Hawaii
their data analysis centers across the
United States PSC Harvard John Hopkins
and also across the Atlantic in England
and so we have a lot of data movement to
do we've done two
experiments so far to demonstrate and
understand what is entailed the first
one is actually very small using PSC is
a staging area the second one where we
did an eight terabyte data movement use
a combination of W get and other means
to transfer data across two oceans and
in doing this learned a lot about the
advantages of our cinco w get one what's
selling to me though is actually this is
all very hard moving data for the users
is a hard thing we have very skilled
people we have network teams working on
this they're working on that are just
backup millet but they're doing these
different methods are doing hand tuning
and they're developing the pipeline this
is a hard thing to do the other thing is
we see the network congestion varies
very widely over time this is just over
a day of course you expect this people
visit different times a day a couple
examples looking at the future there's a
group of carnegie-mellon does seismic
hazard analysis looking at doing
earthquake simulations essentially
deducing subsurface geology what the
robot to is doing very large numbers of
these inverse problems can be able to
predict what likely hazard snares would
be what areas in the Los Angeles basis
Basin would be at risk and so that
becomes very large problem in terms of
data the other thing that's difficult
here is of course what they do is the
simulation so you produce a bunch of
data in time now you want to do
correlation functions analysis over the
time sets so once you're done you what
do you transpose is over these and a
side point I'm going to skip in the
interest of time I could talk about
later is doing statistical analyses of
these large 4d data sets so there are a
couple approaches that I think are
really important here well we see across
the board for all these is data movement
people do computation across the grid
they've across the world they may have
experimental data communed form all over
and they have to do analysis somewhere
yesterday was discussed I guess in
Garth's talk whether or not you I have a
separate analysis cluster next to
compute cluster in external
doing it but we do see that we have
people doing things all over and that's
certainly the way things are moving so
too approachable I talk about very
briefly are things being developed at
PSC to address these problems the first
is de mover which really allows you to
do schedule data transfers over
distributed networks and also to
building work flow characteristics so
there's more here than I have time to go
through the main key though is this
approval harness it lets people very
easily build in FAL transfers their
workflows so a given computational
analysis job may be gated on a data
movement job that can then be scheduled
and the advantages are twofold one is
the people can build workflows to
incorporate data movement into their
overall analysis the second thing is you
could schedule the data movement to take
advantage of periods of lower network
activity so you don't need to provision
that your analysis network bandwidth to
be the worst-case Maxim you has a
provision to be a reasonable sustained
bandwidth and then you can schedule your
data movement accordingly you also can
schedule the day movement according how
much space you may have on your rotating
disk an analysis system so in the
absence of something like this you
typically have an HP SI system or some
large cluster or cloud to do your
analysis and somehow you get your data
in over a grid FTP or something else and
you would do that oops with a movement
day remover you would have some other
nodes your allocated to doing that
specifically and those good exchange
would be the servers it is scheduling
and provide this layer of abstraction
and portability this really removes a
lot of scalability limits it removes
network being your bandwidth the gang
data in because you can schedule this
you can increase your capacity on demand
by increasing those numbers of nodes and
you really provide a scalable
configuration for users the other thing
that lets you do is separate out the
diagnostics and some performance tuning
features out from where they're usually
buried in the system facilities to
things that are being used or visible
now so if the user doesn't get given the
Fowler's said fouls that
do some diagnostics and react
accordingly without administrator and
perhaps transparently and so it has
number another a number of other
advantages it lives over existing
protocols gridded ftp over various forms
of ssh and so on so again this can live
on top of existing protocols one thing
we're focusing on here it's develop
these meta services that can live on top
of whatever other people use other sites
because you won't get people to change
your way of working they do what they're
doing for good reasons but we can
provide a layer of abstraction that lets
them add new functionality performance
and usability on top of whatever they
are all doing so the second thing I want
to mention is / to this has a similar
idea of federating existing systems but
in this case we're looking federating
parallel file systems and so the
parallel file systems may be anything
from lustre down to say Hadoop FS the
idea here is to behave like a file
system but give you other data
management capabilities to have some
relaxed consistency ideas that lets you
roll get higher performance and
flexibility and also ease of use for
users the one thing we hear from users
working grids is they really want this
single namespace this is a good move in
that direction and at the same time it
doesn't require people to change their
underlying phalluses we're not saying
they have to use a lustre gpfs or
anything else the slash name came from
the scalable lightweight archival
storage hierarchy I don't know if it
still stands for anything or not that
began quite a while ago is a project
with National Archives and / to is the
next round of this it's been used in
production for a number of years of PSC
literally handing handling hundreds of
millions of vowels many petabytes of
data and providing very nice cash hit
rates that of course improves
performance and it really lets us
improve capacity by just adding
essential white box level services
rather than more expensive things
again the emphasis on the ease of use so
manages things on behalf of the user
rather you use your having to do the
things I've shown you that people are
doing successfully to facilitate large
data transfers the idea here is you want
to be able to let users do that easily
you will go get maximum performance from
the underlying parallel file system
whatever it happens to be and to be able
to get the files across network and so
this gives very nice cross eyed
archiving certainly the kinds of things
you want to do for these distributed
workflows they can give you Geographic
replication for dated reliability and
okay those are the people I mention of
that slide so for example task of this
one might have output coming from this
is the xe3 at PSC and that might go the
query that or the instruction of the
user might be you may want make a backup
Geographic copy of it somewhere for
security and you may well copy it also
to do some visualizations somewhere else
which may be at the same site your maybe
across some large distance and so what
actually happens there is that under the
covers in / to yet copy made to an
archiver over here get copy made to some
archiver at side b and also a
visualization cluster which can be there
or elsewhere so I've been trying Stan
trap I think the main points here or
that we do have number of cases where
the high performance computing resource
you still want to have some sort of very
large of balance resources easier
analyses it has to have high io
bandwidth typically high memory
bandwidth I'm concern about both because
for a lot of these you're going to be
larger than the physical memory of the
machine whatever that memory happens to
be you need the i/o down with also and
then on top of that you have to give the
users of tools they need whether there
are things like the mover like / so they
can actually do the science they want to
do again see the four o'clock talk to
the science examples
more detail and once you've done that
then you can actually get people to be
able to do things across whether it's a
tear grid or the brother collaboration
they may span several continents so you
have to take questions
okay so trident I don't know in detail
other than conceptually but for instance
I would imagine your beat things that
you can do so d oeuvre will have
functionality that one can invoke and I
could imagine that there may be right so
right now oh ok I would but the question
is if I have my own application of
workflow management I was asking how
easy it is well what do I use to connect
with my workflow application with em
over yeah so in terms of yeah as I said
I have not used tridents I can't really
speak that directly in terms of more
generic workflows it would be on linux
or grid type systems which I may be very
well there'll be commands for say
getting a foul there'll be commands for
gating a execution of some cats maybe
analysis or something else on arrival of
the file now I don't think it's indie
mover now but there's love functionality
by having us a separate layer for being
able to do those scheduling i'm sure
this person d mover for being to do
that's really scheduling system wide so
if you have a number of users ring the
independent workflows i'll give a
resource you don't want them all to be
initiate transferring can tear by 10 at
once so that sort of scheduling is or
things that you can do also to
maximize your role throughput given the
network capacity that you happen to have
right yeah and I'm sure those things can
be done in the same way with with ya if
right Sadie mover would sound top a
great FTP or could that's one layer
could sit on top of and so the same way
your concrete feed now you could call d
mover instead and get a little bit more
flexibility and similarly the Federation
file system series / to that could also
be transparent to a trident layer or
anything else right hey thank you